i'm chris armstrong and we be talking
about doing purely functional
programming at your day job especially
with side effects so i assume a lot of
people were some people in here enjoy
functional programming but few of us in
the kind of greater industry are able to
use it at work a lot of us use
imperative languages like Python Ruby
Java and even fewer of us use like pure
pure functional programming like with
tract effects I'm going to get into that
in a second so who here does use like
only imperative languages at work okay
yeah like most like ninety percent at
least I use Python at work Rackspace
does almost everything in Python
especially in the cloud stuff but it
didn't stop me from doing functional
programming it shouldn't stop you like
everybody can do it any languages is
capable do it doing it and it's not that
hard especially because there are a lot
of libraries available for popular
languages so if pipe in Python I
personally use tool tools II and
persistent a lot tools these kind of
general purpose you know higher-order
functions kind of neat utilities for
iterators and stuff like that all purely
functional and persistent is an
implementation of a rayche rebased data
structures like the closures data
structures for pythons pretty performant
ruby has similar things like functional
Ruby and hamster respectively similar
javascript has like 15 different things
of course that I'll try to do the same
thing with slight variations the
functional jas library actually
differentiate self differentiates itself
from underscore in argument order which
is its kind of relevant if you're doing
curry but you know it's pretty minor
there's also languages like
clojurescript elm and pierre script
which compile to JavaScript which are
really neat Java has functional Java I
haven't like looked at it too closely
but it looks kind of neat and of course
the the language is the functional
languages that compile to to java like
closure and Scala all of these give you
a nice kind of standard library for
functional programming and given give
you a nice immutable data structures
that are performance
but in most of these things other than
like almond peer scripts I think
implicit effects are still really common
like you just when you're when you're
writing something to the Internet you
just do it like and it's in the middle
of a function right and you it's not
tracked anywhere even like yeah so like
if you're a go camel program or Scala
racket like it all works like that so
for the rest of this talk I'll refer to
implicit side effects as Yolo it's a
transitive verb it means it's what you
do to global state or external
interfaces when you have an implicit
side effect for example this function
yellow is an accumulator every time it's
called & javas URL objects Yolo the
internet when you try to compare them
for a quality what so how do we deal
with these side effects without doing a
yellow first we try not to have them
like a lot of times you can just work
factor stuff so that you don't actually
have side effects you just use a better
factoring functional data structures
like the first example you know you can
accumulate things by returning like a
bigger list or something every time but
you know some of some side effects are
actually necessary a lot of side effects
any kind of Internet communication
displaying things to screen reading
input sharing state between threads all
of these are intrinsically side-effect
phul so the way we deal with this is x
ray applying them as values in other
words we make them first class objects
in our system and this is exactly how
Haskell's io types work there they're
objects that represent you know in
effect and so for example the print
function in haskell it doesn't actually
print anything it returns a value that
shows the intent it represents the
intent to print and once you return this
value from from the main function in
your Haskell program the Haskell runtime
performs it so why would you actually
want to do this well in some sense this
makes your code more modular it makes it
purely functional and that has all the
intended benefits of a purely functional
code you can kind of reason about it
with the crazy equational reasoning
you can compose and and you know
refactor your code a little bit more
reasonably but specifically the thing I
care about a lot is testing I really
like unit testing I'm a Python
programmer so I'm like one of those
people who's like really into unit
testing and even when i come to the type
world I'm like all right I need to
figure out how to you know do this so
even in high school I come on up I kind
of want to do this and also I hate mocks
I assume other people hate walks I'm
just going to assume that especially if
you use Python the mock API is really
bad in Python and I just don't want to
do that I don't want to touch it so you
know I want a better way and this is how
I kind of approach this problem so I'm
going to show how I implemented tract
effects in Python there's a library I
wrote called effect and I'm going to
show how I implemented it so you know I
not everybody here use Python you use
other languages you will be able to go
home and or go back to your job or
whatever and work on a library like this
for whatever language you use and I'd
love to see more more things like this
some language is going to be better than
others at giving it a nice syntax but
you know usually if you don't even if
you don't have this impacts it can be me
pretty useful and I as a bonus I also
kind of implemented this idea of a
testable effect in Haskell and because
Haskell's io types aren't actually
testable like they're they're a nice
rarefied representation of an effect but
you can't introspective you can't look
at them all you can do is perform them
so yeah I wanted to come up with I
wanted to use the same nifty API that I
implemented for for my system and
Haskell I'll get to that later and any
high schoolers can make fun of my code
because i'm a noob so okay let's get to
some code here's a yellow function in
Python it asks you for a name it prints
out a greeting ask you for another name
prints out another greeting and returns
a 2-tuple of those things so yeah how do
we how do we test this typically in
Python look like that i pasted this code
on my slide and I didn't even want to
fix it because like it's too much I
don't want to go over
at all this is the mock module basically
what we're doing is we're monkey
patching replacing it runtime the raw
input and print functions and then we do
a bunch of garbage to make sure that
they like return the right simulated
values and expect the right arguments
and all that stuff and it's just a mess
so what we actually what I want to say
is that like what I want to how I want
to formulate my test is there should be
a sequence of expected effects that are
performed in a specific order and then I
want to check the final result of the
function the Greek function the funny
thing is that last slide didn't even
implement like ensuring that the order
was right because in the mock module
that's even harder it's like it's a mess
so it's important that if we change the
order of effects in our in our code that
the test should fail because it can be
really important order orders is matters
big time so yeah it's kind of getting to
the point of my talk which is that you
know your side effects need to be tested
as much as the return function is a
return value of your functions you know
you might break something like for
example if you have if we if we asked
for those two names in different if we
like asked for both names upfront and
then printed both greetings like that
would be a significant difference in our
behavior in the function like it's not
something that you want to accidentally
refactor and then allow that to happen
you know unless you intended to do it
and so that you want your test to be
careful that another example is like if
you have multiple locks you know it's
really important to lock locks in the
choir locks in the same order everywhere
and you want to like make sure that
you're testing it testing that it's
doing doing things in the right order
and so yeah like by definition a side
effect is something that's observable
and when something is observable you
want it you want to consider it at least
when you're defining your contract with
your end users and you also want to test
anything that is in your contract with
your end users so yeah I like to think
of side effects kind of as a log
whenever I run a function and it has
side effects I want to think about
exactly like you know a nice
representation of the side effects
that happened as kind of a sequence or a
log and that's kind of how the effect
library's testing API works but I'll
show you that in a bit so here I'm going
to this is me porting the Yolo code to
an effect to my effect library I use
this decorator called do and it kind of
it assumes that your function is going
to be a generator function which is what
that yields syntax is and it kind of
iterates your generator your function
with a with some special behavior so the
prompt functions the prompt and display
functions are like raw input and print
they were but they returned effects and
so when you yield in effect inside of a
do function that's basically saying hey
resume me resume this function when the
result of this effect is available right
and so then it'll go on to the yield
display and then you know and so on at
the end we have a yield do return thing
which is kind of just some like genki
syntax that works around some
limitations in Python 2 in Python 3 you
can just say return statement as normal
the last important thing to know is that
the do decorator makes your function
return in effect so not only is it
giving you a way to deal with effects
inside of the function it makes you you
know your your function return in effect
so I'm going to show you how this
translates to the lower level version
which should clarify it a bit yeah let's
go anyone who's seen Haskell code like
the do notation being destroyed to the
kind of bind in lambda it like this
should look very similar it's like a
staircase where basically so each each
effect object has an on method which is
very similar to monads bind you give it
a function and it returns you a new
effect it's a little bit different from
bind because it has some special error
handling stuff and some other stuff but
that's not really that important so yeah
you don't feel like understand this too
much unless you do want to implement
something like it but i'm going to show
you the effect class itself and how
effects are actually represented this is
almost exactly the definition that i use
in
in my effect library of effect it's
really simple obviously all it is is
it's an effect is an object with an
intent and some callbacks it couldn't
even be simpler but as an optimization
I'm a callbacks a list instead of just
having a single call back it's just a
performance thing but you know so the
interesting thing here is well what's an
intent well it's it's whatever you want
it to be it's it can literally be any
object the the core effect library
doesn't care I encourage you to make it
an immutable object with a kind of a
transparent data structure with public
attributes so it's nicely into
respectable and stuff and it should also
support quality mostly to enable the
testing API which will get which I'll
get to later so I'll show you what some
of the intents are that I defined in in
my library so here are display and
prompt like these are the objects that
those those functions were returning I'm
using a library called actress here just
to make it kind of more terse like
really all that saying is you know
display is a class and it takes an
output argument and it assigns it to the
output attribute so it's just a like
nice utility library it gives you a
quality hashing all that kind of stuff
that you want on your objects on your
immutable objects in Python prompt is
similar so the important thing to note
here is that there's no behavior on
these on these classes there's nothing
that's like here's how you display
something or here's how you prompt it's
just like it's just representing the
intent to do these things and that's
that's pretty important important so
let's think about what like this effect
for Greek function right so now that we
know what we know we know that this
function doesn't do anything it just
returns in effect and that effect
doesn't know how to like perform itself
or anything like that and there's an
important part of effects designed
there's a forced separation between
intent and performance right it makes
your code more modular so you know we
could have different implementations of
performers for prompt and display like
that either use standard i/o or use like
some gooey thing or whatever it also you
know
another example would be like if you
have like an HTTP request intent you
might want to have like a blocking
implementation of it that that uses like
the requests library and Python or you
might want to use something like twisted
and your application code doesn't need
to care what the backend is so this is
this is a nice way to kind of normalize
that and abstract away kind of like
nitty gritty side effect details so I'm
going to show you how to actually
perform something like this if you're
writing a program and you want to write
the main function so it's it's not that
interesting you can do this in different
ways this is the way I did in the effect
library just to like maximize modularity
and usability and stuff but so basically
there's this dispatcher system and
dispatcher is an object that when given
in it you give it an intent and it
returns a performer so it's pretty
simpler you usually it looks up the the
performer to use by type so i'm going to
show you so this is a a performer for
the display intent right and this is
where we actually do the yellow like
this is where we call the print the
built-in print function which has an
implicit side effect right and we're
going to have to test this the
old-fashioned way like this is you know
we need to do mocking or whatever
patching but we only have to do that
once for this performer function right
like all the rest of our application
code is abstract it's it's it's like
first-class effects and we can use the
nicer testing api's for that so here's
here's how we construct a dispatcher
it's I'm using type dispatcher and it's
just saying whenever you get a display
intent run this perform display function
it's pretty simple and finally once we
have the dispatcher and the effect we
call this sink perform function which
takes the dispatcher in effect and it
basically interprets the effect it walks
through the effect it says okay what's
the intent on this I'm going to look up
the performer for it and run it and then
call all the callbacks on that effect
and then if they return more effects I'm
going to kind of recurse and go through
that so it's it's just it's the core
thing that you want to run in your in
your main function of your program you
know I the ideal effect based program
only has one call to sync perform and
it's
your main function but you know if
you're integrating this into an existing
code base you want to do it gradually
you can use sync perform you sprinkle it
throughout your code base wherever you
want to introduce some more pure code
you know and then you just use sync
perform to kind of turn it into a yellow
ok so I've been talking about I've been
like dropping references to the testing
API for a while I'm going to actually
show you how it works you know
originally I was writing code I didn't
have like a nicer test API but I was
just using everything that I had
everything that i showed you to do test
so I would just write a custom performer
and you know register with the
dispatcher and just run through the
effects and you know it was it was nice
because all my code was pure and I could
I can reason about it but it was it was
pretty just verbose so I came up with a
nicer API and this is where I get into
that like sequence of affects the the
log of effects kind of thing so here the
first thing we do is we declare the
expected effects that are going to be
performed in like what when I run this
function right and it's a it's a list of
two tuples so we have the the first
element in each tuple is the intent that
we expect and so this is where the
Equality of your intense is important
because equality is used to match the
intense so first thing we expect is a
prompt and the second item each tuple is
a function that simulates the the
performance or simulates the return
value of that effect and so we're going
to simulate that whenever we get
prompted to enter your name I'm going to
return radix and then and then so on so
it's kind of interesting to note how the
the data flows through this which I
thought was really neat it's like
reflected very well in this so like if
you simulate returning radix and the
first effect the second effect is going
to use that result in in what you know
in the next intent or the next effect
that it performs so I think that's
that's just a kind of a nice reflection
of the way the data flows through your
code finally once we have the expected
sequence we perform it with performed
sequence which is another interpreter
you know just like sync performance
actually it's
amended in on top of sync perform it's
kind of just a utility function and it
just builds a dispatcher based on that
sequence that we've declared and then
finally it returns the while it doesn't
look like it should sorry about that and
then it finally returns the the ultimate
result and you know we assert against it
good okay so one of the things that I'm
really proud of in this API is a when
you when you have a bug when something
doesn't match up it gives you this
really nice descriptive error message of
what just happened so here we it's not
that important but it's it's something
that you know gives it a like a nice
amount of polish to using the library so
this log is like okay we tried to get a
we expected or we got an effect that
said Greeks ace and we couldn't find it
and so it's saying each c2 line prefixed
with sequence is like here's an intent
that I found and I performed and it was
you know it was correct and then the not
found line is like here's what I tried
to run and I couldn't find it it wasn't
in your sequence but the next expected
thing was this and you know I just
inserted a bug here i misspelled greets
with some some higher bites so yeah this
this helps a lot when you're debugging
effect and yeah I think it's important
to have this kind of stuff okay so
that's it that's everything that's the
core part of the effect library if
that's all you you know if you like
wanna use effect you know that should be
enough to get you going if you want to
re-implement it another language it
should be enough I'm going to talk about
a few other points just like briefly in
some things that I kind of figured out
about effect after I used it in
production for a while and then I'm
going to move on to the Haskell these
things so one of the first things I did
was actually did anybody here know what
twisted is for Python okay decent amount
of people I like I've been working on
twisted since like on a 2001 or
something like that and you know we use
it in the application that I work work
on at Rackspace and so we needed like it
I found myself doing a lot of
coordination between effects and twisted
and so I wanted to write a library that
kind of made that easy so twisted has
these things called deferred switch are
very similar promises if you know what
that means they're a representation of
an asynchronous result it's a result
that you don't have yet and that is
pretty similar to effects like there
they have an API where you add a call
back to them and your callback will get
called when when the result is available
so effect is pretty similar the
difference is that deferred zar are
mutable whenever you add a call back it
actually mutates the deferred you're
adding it to an effect gives you a new
effect whenever you add a call back and
so yeah I just wrote a nice library it
gives you some performers some
asynchronous performers for a lot of the
intents and it's in this library called
TX effect so if you're interested in
another kind of neat thing is I defined
a parallel effects intent which you give
it you basically give it a list of
effect and it's saying ok I intend these
to be run in parallel right and there
are multiple ways to run stuff in
parallel right like you can use thread
you can be extinct Ernest so there's a
built-in performer in effect that uses
threads for the parallel effects so you
can you know use requests library or
whatever to you know just like and wrap
them up in effects and and run them in
parallel threads or if you're using TX
effect you can use the Twisted client
web client and do that and your
application code stays the same but you
know you can use it in either
environment so it's it's really nice for
library it's like if you want to write a
library that's kind of generic between a
bunch of like that's agnostic to the
decisions that the deployers will make
its pretty valuable so the tests are
also yeah I guess it's not as about this
time kind of a agnostic to that so here
we're using it's another like sequence
of effects followed by a perform
sequence thing we're using a little
utility function here that's basically
saying I expect whenever I'm testing
this code I expect there to be a get to
google and a get to yahoo and those are
going to be the results
it'sit's ensuring that their run in
parallel right and this is all without
actually performing anything so it's
pretty pretty handy that's not the
parallel seek function is not yet in the
effect library it's in my work code base
but I'm going to be migrating it there
probably within a week okay one kind of
last interesting point is that so I
often find myself kind of abstracting
over effects with more effects so an
example of that is so like say I want to
create a cloud server like a rackspace
cloud server and I have this function
create cloud server I might you know
implement that in terms of a make HTTP
request serve a function that you know
does the kind of low-level HTTP to you
know I want to post something to the
rackspace API like two servers endpoint
and create something if that's
implemented you know that might be
implemented in a very low level or in
terms of a very low level intent like
right bytes to network right you know so
it's like connect to the socket and
write exactly these bites right like
that's that's super low level if we do
that the tests end up being pretty ugly
you know you're trying to test this like
create cloud server function which is
like way up here in terms of abstraction
but your tests are like Oh what are the
bites on the network that's not what we
actually want to test and so what I end
up doing is creating a kind of more
abstract intent like for example HTTP
request which represents you know it
takes a method and a URL and some you
know parameters or whatever and it's
just saying like I expect there to be an
HTTP request made and so that way you
know if you're using that in your make
HTTP request function then your tests
are a little bit higher level you can
even go further than that and like make
an intent for each kind of API operation
you want to do like create cloud server
which you know further makes it further
makes your tests nice and it also you
know gives you more opportunity for
modularity so if you want to like swap
out the performers like swap out the way
that create cloud server is implemented
you know in terms of different things
and basically whenever you do one of
these abstractions you just write a
performer for
in tents like create cloud server that
returns another effect and so you're
still getting you're basically getting
the stack of effects that's it and yeah
it works out pretty nicely so one last
point about effects is that you
shouldn't use them if you don't need to
so just like you want to avoid implicit
side effects it's also good to avoid
explicit side effects even if you are
tracking them even there if they are
pure objects there's still more more
complex than you know simple data simple
data structures you know it affects
encode behavior not just not just data
right there they have this intent which
is just data but then they also have a
call back or some callbacks and you know
you have to once you have that you need
to like do more work to test them you
need to use this API that I made and
even though it's nice it's still like
it's it's more complex than like is a
equal to be right so yeah I have some I
don't really have enough time to go into
the lessons I learned specifically
around this in my in my work application
but you know if you want to catch me at
lunch or whatever i can i can tell you
but yeah just you know keep that in mind
don't don't like go overboard you know
like oh just because this is pure now i
can just use it everywhere like you
still want to kind of isolate them so
now on to the high school stuff that's
all the python stuff i know this is like
there's probably not a lot of people who
were that intersectional with like
python and haskell but i like them both
so i'm giving a talk about both so if
you looked at the talk description you
see that i mentioned that i would have
interesting hasko content i'll describe
some ideas and techniques that even most
high schoolers could use to make their
code more easy easily testable oh boy so
i was struggling with some of the type
stuff when I was working on this port of
my code to Haskell and I was under
pressure with a deadline and so I did
what you do I posted to stack overflow
and thankfully a day later one of the
prolific Stack Overflow errs named see
your deck really saved me he gave me a
solution to wrong the the type problem
that I was having so thanks CEO deck
so free monads anyone ever heard the
phrase free monad okay yeah all right so
there are some people who read some
Haskell blogs here they're getting
pretty pretty popular especially among
bloggers and in the Haskell world so
basically they're pretty simple if you
know what I monett is they're basically
they just they're a data structure that
that represents monads in the simplest
way you can with no extra stuff so all
they do is they record like it's just a
data structure that has the has kind of
a an intent that's not what it's usually
called in in that in the literature but
you know it's basically some some object
in a DSL or something and and the other
thing that it records is the the
function that you've bound to it so
that's it it's just like effect there's
a couple of libraries that implement
this idea you can also i mean it's it's
a few lines of code to kind of implement
it from scratch but these libraries give
you kind of a nice some some attendant
functions that are that are useful free
is the basic one you just basically
define a little data structure of your
your dsl is what they or a store
abstract syntax tree whatever you want
to call it and then you wrap it around
free or frappe wrap free around it and
it gives you the Monad operational is
another 1i slightly prefer it it just
lets you define the dsl and a slightly
nicer way it doesn't really matter what
you use you can do this stuff with both
of them so here is the the intent thing
the the dsl that i called intent because
it's really the same as before there are
two of them to two constructors for this
type prompt which takes a string to
prompt the user with and a results in a
string display takes a string and
results in nothing a result in unit
because display doesn't have a return
value so we take this this type we wrap
it with program which is from the
operational library and it just gives
you a free Mona back so my effect of a
is a program that when run results in a
and then after that we just kind of lift
the the constructors up into
to the Monad with these the singleton
function which is also from operational
if you're familiar with free it's called
lift F there so yeah that this is
equivalent to everything else in my
Python implementation like it's all here
on this slide granted using the free
monad library like saved me a lot of
stuff so but yeah Pascal's pretty nice
isn't it and here's the program it's
exactly the same as the Python version I
showed you it's prompting for a name
printing out a greeting prompting for
another name putting other grading and
returning that the two two names it's
pretty pretty readable I think and
here's the test for it and this is where
C or that helped me it's it's a it's
very similar to that perform sequence
thing I was showing you it's it's laying
out the effects to be run in this
specific order and it basically what
it's doing is it's building up an
interpreter that specifically that
expects a specific sequence of
instructions and it this interpreter is
custom-crafted for that exact program
I'm not super happy with this
formulation because you see like there's
check prompts check display there's
these specific functions for each kind
of intent and like if you write a you
know I had a lot of intense in my in my
work system I don't want to write these
little functions so I'm sure there's a
way to do to like make this polymorphic
I just haven't figured it out yet so
yeah here's an example of check prompt
so it's it might look a little complex
but it's it's pretty simple highlighted
some of the interesting things so chick
pump check cron takes the expected
prompt like the you know enter your name
it takes the response that you want to
simulate so radix and the program so
that's like the effect and it pattern
matches on the program using the view
function which is from operational it's
basically just you know give me the kind
of the head of this program and if the
first instruction or the next
instruction in the program is a prompt
and that prompt string matches you know
is equal to what we expect then we're
going to continue and we're going to
continue with the simulated response
that's the Conte response the Conte does
what's balanced
the to the UM to the instruction like
that with the bind operator so yeah it's
there's also check display and check
return which are very similar so they
just check the different kinds of
effects you can have like I said it's
really like I'm sure that I can abstract
this and make this smaller and more
polymorphic so there's only one check
function I just need to learn more
hassle so yeah if any way you can help
me with that would be great one last
point Fremaux dad's like it you know if
you've if you're like on any of the
mailing lists or reddit like you've
probably seen Edward commit talking
about how free monads are slow and you
know like if you just use a direct like
implementation it's faster you don't
have to worry about that too much
because at least one of the ways you can
you can deal with that is you can make
it so that in production your code is
just using I oh right like so what you
would do is one one example of what you
could do is put the prompt and display
functions in a type class make an
instance of that type class for i/o that
just does the stuff directly and then in
testing you make an instance of it for
your free monad and in your test you're
like ok interpret this program is a free
monad or run this you know run this
function as a as type of my free mode
that I won't add that I care about and
you get this data structure back instead
of just performing it directly so this
is a way you can / avoid that overhead
in production this is probably
nitty-gritty but you know if you're
super paranoid about the performance
then it can be useful so yeah that's
that's it you know isolate your side
effects it's it's really nice it makes
it makes it more testable more modular
you get to stop using the mock module so
that's it thank you
so I think I have time for questions if
anybody has any so I have in my app we
use Cassandra oh sorry yes how do I
handle a database effect so we use
Cassandra am I am the app at work we
have an intent called execute cql which
you know it's the Cassandra query
language and so you know whenever we
have a function that wants to do some
database stuff we you know just use that
perform sequence thing and it's like
okay well I expect this query in this
query in this query as side effects when
i run this this function and then we
also have in some cases you know I was
talking about abstracting effects
because X execute sequel cql can get a
little bit tedious if you're working in
higher level level application code and
you want to test some higher level
function we also have a few intense that
abstract over that the like you know
some stuff that's specific to our domain
like create scaling group or whatever
it's an auto scaling system so scaling
group is one of the model objects in our
system we have an intent called create
scaling group and so you know if we're
doing that a lot then we'll do that will
make that abstraction and then test in
terms of that so that answer okay and
the others
what if you want to sneak in a generator
it also has a what effect I'm not I
don't think I quite follow it a you know
generate light look what so one of the
right yes yeah you cannot compose monads
right so there's only one monad here
that's the way I get around it like
there's only this is essentially only
the IO monad and so you know there is no
pure like state monad or whatever in the
system so it works out so that I don't
have the problems of composition of
monads because I only have one and you
know at the expense of not having more
specific monads that have specific
behavior also it's only sequential right
like you you could write interpreters
for effect that do different things but
like in practice you know you can't
implement the list monad in terms of
effect because you can't jump backwards
in in in the in the generator in Python
so yeah any others yep
so the question is does this only apply
when you don't need previous data to
determine what your next steps are no it
works for that you you it just like
that's actually the power of monad over
applicative if you're familiar with
Haskell like so applicative you can't
use previous data to make decisions
about what you're going to do next in
monads you can so and this is very
similar to a monad so you you get the
data you get the result of the previous
effect and remember how i was showing
like how in that one example like i was
simulating radix being returned from the
the first prompt and the second display
the display had radix in it so it was
using that and I could have put a
conditional in there to say if it's
radix do this effect if it's this do not
affect and that's actually where that
sequential testing API like really
shines because you know what you'll do
is you'll write a few different tests
for the same code passing in different
data that makes it take different code
bats and you'll just see that like ok
this code path results in this series
effects that code path results in that
series of minutes so it's it's pretty
it's pretty powerful
so yeah the question is yeah so question
is like you end up where most of your
code like most of your stack is running
inside of the performance system of you
know performing in tents which returned
more intense and and so on it yeah like
a lot of times that does happen and it's
you know it's it you want it you still
like it here like I said you kind of
want to minimize the amount of effects
that you have but you know generally
they they are at the top right it's kind
of like if you've ever heard Gary
Bernhardt talk about functional core
imperative she'll like the shell is kind
of like your main function right and
that's imperative that's using effect
and then you have little bits of pure
functions inside so yeah like if you get
a trace back out of something you're
going to see effect stuff in there
you're going to see a perform you know
and then you know whatever performer was
happening so yeah I mean that that's
true any others don't see any okay well
that's it thank you very much